the killing of nine Palestinians in
Janine yesterday was the deadliest day
in the West Bank for two decades
and once again has brought Israel and
Palestinians to the edge of a new war
Israel says it was acting on
intelligence and that the raid foiled
imminent Terror attacks
51 year old Palestinian woman was killed
in the crossfire though
overnight Rockets were fired from Gaza
into Southern Israel in retaliation the
Israeli military intercepted them and
launched their own airstrikes against
Hamas Targets in the strip
Annapolis like Janine has been the
center of Palestinian resistance
balata which is on the edge of the city
is the largest refugee camp in the West
Bank and is regularly raided by Israeli
forces hunting their enemy
we were taken through the narrow
claustrophobic Alleyways to meet them
we've been taking the fighters from the
Alexa Brigade one of the biggest
militant groups in the West Bank this is
their stronghold they're in regular
fights with Israeli forces here
and they've agreed to speak to us on
camera
they are young men heavily armed and say
they're ready to die defending their
land
is
an Israeli observation tower looks down
to the camp from a surrounding Hill the
IDF watches and listens to everything
going on
in the West Bank in the bigger region
some people say there'll be a third in
tifada do you think there will be a
popular uprising
[Music]
the Alleyways of nabus's Old City are
decorated in posters celebrating dead
militants
many of them killed in recent months
Israel says they were terrorists but for
many young Palestinians they are heroes
Martyrs who died fighting the Israeli
occupation and a talk of a new interfada
is growing louder
I think that there is individa is coming
do you think a 13 to Father yes I think
that if there is why
there are not hope you know my people
was shot dead by Israeli forces one
morning earlier this month he was on his
way to work with his son kusai in the
car beside him they were caught at a
temporary checkpoint and when drivers
started to get frustrated the Israeli
soldiers fired a stun grenade at the car
that Ahmed and kusai were in and then
sprayed them with tear gas
Ahmed got out for the car to remonstrate
and the soldiers shot him
[Music]
what is your feeling towards the Israeli
soldiers who shot your father
and towards
Israelis in general
do you think
there will ever be Justice for what
happened to your father no
50 .
initially the IDF claimed that Ahmed had
a knife and had tried to attack the
soldiers
they later changed the story and
admitted he was unarmed
many of the Palestinians killed by
Israeli forces are militants but
increasingly innocent civilians are
caught up in the escalating violence
it adds to a sense of hopelessness and
anger which is why so many young men in
particular are taking up arms and
turning to violence
right now any Prospect of peace talks or
even a two-state solution feels a long
way off
neither side is in the mood to talk or
to compromise
Aleister Michael Sky News in Annapolis
in the West Bank